the united nations secretary general is
calling for a diplomatic solution to the
north korean crisis the u.s response to
pyongyang's nuclear threat is the
subject of this morning of our ongoing
series issues that matter south korea's
navy conducted live fire drills
yesterday to show its military force
after north korea's largest nuclear test
sunday the u.s wants stricter sanctions
on kim jong-un's regime as his nation
possibly prepares for a new missile test
former defense secretary ash carter
spent more than three decades working on
national security issues in both
republican and democratic
administrations he was involved in
military planning during the 1994 crisis
over north korea's nuclear program he's
now the director of the belfast center
at the harvard kennedy school and joins
us this morning ash carter this is
certainly your territory so we're very
curious to see what you're thinking
these days you've heard secretary mattis
say this thank you that the u.s would
respond to any threat by north korea in
his words massive military response
sounds very scary sounds very intense
what type of threat would warrant that
type of response what does that mean
when you hear that
well we've been prepared and continue to
prepare for decades for north korean
aggression we are very well prepared
it's important that we protect our
people
as well as our friends and allies from
north korea i think at this juncture
what i would advise is a
strategy of coercive diplomacy you know
people talk about is it diplomacy or is
it military action in general in
strategic affairs and certainly in this
case what you need is a mix
in which you
require north korea to take steps
progressively to reduce the threat
or you take steps progressively to in
military and economic sanctions
to apply pressure to them if down the
road they continue to make the wrong
choice
and this road it does in fact lead to
military conflict we have had the time
first of all
better to prepare our forces even than
the considerable preparation that they
have now
our allies japan and south korea and
also to sideline japan and those are
necessary prep preparations for
effective military uh action but i think
at this juncture it's coercive diplomacy
the mix of the military and the
diplomatic that's the package you just
said
but you just said if they make the wrong
choice what is the wrong choice that
would warrant massive military action
what do we need to see some people say
firing these test missiles is a very
disconcerting thing
well they're all disconcerting it's been
going on for quite some time i think
that uh what we need them to do is
halt
underground testing of nuclear weapons
halt
uh tests of ballistic missiles not fire
ballistic missiles of long range in our
direction or the direction of our allies
and at each step of the way they can
either take that step in back from this
brink or toward the brink in either case
we will be prepared either to relax
pressure on them or to increase pressure
on them and as you say
down the road
after if they continue to make bad
choices uh military action may be
necessary i think secretary mattis is
pointing to our readiness to do that and
the possible necessity to do uh that um
but after coercive diplomacy plays out
in this way we are better prepared uh if
that eventuality occurs which it will
make and as you know the question has
been whether china and russia will
engage in that course of diplomacy into
the way that that may be needed
president trump is having a phone call
this morning with the chinese president
xi jinping is it time for the chinese to
cut off the oil supply to the north
well absolutely it's been
for some time
in what i would regard as china's best
strategic interest in the long run to
apply its ability to essentially
strangle north korea increase
importantly
through energy to get them to
stop doing something which could lead to
a war
on china's border we will win that war
uh but it is a very very unpleasant war
for us but also for china however as you
say i've been observing this for decades
now uh and it's hard to be optimistic
because the chinese have consistently
disappointed so i think we also need to
prepare ourselves and prepare our
friends and allies and if the chinese
sideline themselves
then
that's unfortunate for them unfortunate
for us but we will be prepared to
protect our people and our friends and
allies secretary how did we get here in
the first place i know privately some
feel the obama administration was too
restrained
on north korea would you agree with that
assessment
well this has been going on for decades
it goes back as as you pointed out
multiple administrations of both parties
the chinese uh the rather than north
koreans first
tested nuclear weapons in 2006
they were launching ballistic missiles
in the 1990s uh so it's been getting
worse and uh
do you think more should have been done
than under the last two years of the
bush administration and then the eight
years of the obama administration do you
think more could have been done well i
certain
i i certainly think we had some success
some limited success in the 1990s this
was mentioned earlier with something
which was essentially coercive diplomacy
a step uh step-by-step progressive
intensification of pressure or
relaxation of pressure depending upon
whether north korea took steps in the
right direction i still think that's the
right way to go
it's a mixture of diplomacy and military
and as i said if that
if the
north koreans continue to make bad
choices
it will lead uh in all likelihood to
greater military action but we will be
better prepared we will position more
forces
on the korean peninsula that may be
necessary that's been discussed
sanctions you've mentioned uh important
also providing advanced systems to our
allies south korea and japan because
they will be an inevitable part of any
military action because remember the
north koreans hate them as much as they
hate us and they threaten them and
they're right there and they're our
friends
and allies and so there are ways in
which through this process we can both
give a try uh to the possibility of of
diplomacy succeeding but also position
ourselves progressively in a strength
strengthened posture
if and when military action is required
which it
may well be ash carter thank you very
much joining us from harvard kennedy
schools uh belfor so we appreciate your
time